[Musik]
guten abend in allen zu einem kurzen
nachrichtenüberblick wir beginnen mit
den vielen fragen die die politik noch
zu klären hat rund um das impfen in
deutschland im kanzleramt gab es dazu
heute einen gipfel von bund und länder
ein wichtiges thema die impfung für
kinder und jugendliche damit verbunden
ist die frage ist dafür überhaupt genug
impfstoff da auch weil anfang juni ja
noch die priorisierung wegfällt
und dann ist da noch der zeitdruck den
digitalen impfpass vor den sommerferien
an den start zu bringen christian
hübsche nach vier stunden beratungen
laden kanzlerin und berlins regierender
bürgermeister müller zur impfgipfel
pressekonferenz markus söder lässt sich
aus bayern zu schalten
merkels wichtigste botschaft richtet
sich an familien mit kindern ab zwölf
kinder und jugendliche können dann ab
dem ende der priorisierung sie wissen
dass am 7.6 im allgemeinen die
priorisierung aufgehoben wird sich auch
um einen impftermin bemühen
entweder eben bei niedergelassenen
ärzten oder auch gegebenenfalls in den
impfzentren das für die kinder extra
impfstoff eingekauft wird oder woanders
abgeknapst wird das aber werde nicht
passieren
wir haben dafür keine zusätzlichen
impfstoffe das war glaube ich der
entscheidende punkt der in den letzten
wochen vielleicht das ein oder andere
mal etwas schief rübergekommen ist
impfstoff bleibt knapp das zeigt auch
dieses papier aus dem hause spahn es ist
unklar mit welchen liefermengen genau im
juni und juli zu rechnen ist im
kanzleramt versichern sie heute unisono
reisen und schule
beides geht immer auch ohne impfung wir
wollen angebote machen aber es gibt
keine impfpflicht es ganz wichtig schule
ist trotzdem nicht mit hochdruck werde
er außerdem am digitalen impfnachweis
gearbeitet als qr code fürs handy
wie hier in brandenburg laufen
testprojekte an am ersten juli soll der
digital pass europaweit gelten
prima cosa bella dzi in berlin mit dazu
guten haben contra die länder hatten ja
heute morgen noch ziemlich viele fragen
und auch viel ärger
was hat sie denn dann in der sitzung
besänftigt da scheint es zwei zentrale
punkte gegeben zu haben zum einen wurde
die ursprüngliche idee fallen gelassen
dass für kinder extra impfstoff
reserviert wird für eigene eine eigene
kampagne angela merkel sagte in der
pressekonferenz
jetzt war keine reservierung stattfindet
wird auch niemand mehr schlechter
gestellt und mit dem wegfall dieser
kinder impfkampagne gibt es auch kein
durcheinander bei der im freien folge
auch das war eine befürchtung der
bundesländer
wer seine über zwölfjährigen kinder
impfen lassen möchte muss sich genauso
ein rein wie alle anderen auch die
abnehmen 76 mit dem wegfall der
priorisierung sich um termine bewerben
können
trotzdem ist es schon erstaunlich dass
es diese einmütige entscheidung jetzt
gegeben hat denn die länder sind
tatsächlich mit relativ viel groll rein
gegangen und hatten vorher auch gesagt
sie wollen eine empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission abwarten die ist jetzt
noch nicht da und das weiß worauf es
jetzt hinausläuft ist wohl dass eltern
dann selber entscheiden müssen wenn die
stiko keine empfehlung abgibt für eine
impfung ab 12 jahren
wie sie damit umgehen wollen das ist
eine bürde die sich viele leute
sicherlich gerne erspart hätten function
controller management werde in vielen
dank dafür
um den gipfel und dessen ergebnisse geht
es jetzt gerade auch bei zdf heute live
gast in der sendung karl lauterbach zu
sehen in unserer zdf heute ab und dort
gibt es auch alle aktuellen
entwicklungen in einem corona blog
weitere wichtige nachrichten dieses
tages jetzt sechs jahre verhandlungen
jetzt der durchbruch deutschland bekennt
sich zum völkermord an den herero und
ist so wiedergutmachung bereit das
bestätigt die regierung in namibia
danach sollen in den nächsten 30 jahren
rund 1,1 milliarden euro in
aufbauprojekte fließen deutscher
kolonialtruppen hatten anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts zehntausende
herero getötet andreas künast die
verhandlungen waren vertraulich sie
fanden abwechselnd in berlin und in
windhoek statt
heute melden namibias medien den
durchbruch deutschland bietet projekte
im wert von 18 milliarden namibischen
dollar an
113 jahre lang hat das volk der herero
auf das eine wort gewartet es war
völkermord jetzt endlich spricht
deutschland es aus 1904 gab
generalleutnant von trotha in deutsch
südwestafrika den befehl einen aufstand
der herero niederzuschlagen bis in die
wüste trieben die deutschen das volk von
dem zwei drittel verdunsteten oder in
den ersten konzentrationslagern ums
leben kamen
mit 1,1 milliarden euro über 30 jahre
hinweg will deutschland jetzt projekte
der nachfahren unterstützen aber einige
von ihnen protestieren weil berlin nicht
mit den herero sondern mit der regierung
verhandelt hat wie kann man über uns
sprechen ohne uns und ohne unser mandat
deutschland will alle herero überzeugen
damit bundespräsident steinmeier noch
dieses jahr in namibia um vergebung
bitten kann
union und spd haben sich doch noch auf
einen kompromiss beim lieferketten
gesetz geeinigt damit könnte es noch vor
der bundestagswahl verabschiedet werden
das gesetz soll unternehmen in
deutschland verpflichten in ihren
lieferketten im ausland gewisse
standards einzuhalten
beispielsweise beim umweltschutz und bei
den arbeitsbedingungen das ziel
kinderarbeit ausbeutung und
naturzerstörung einzudämmen
und es gab heute einen wichtigen
startschuss in sachen stromversorgung
norwegen und deutschland sind ab jetzt
mit einem dicken stromkabel verbunden
die nord link trasse im meer verläuft
von schleswig holstein bis nach
südnorwegen und bringt die erneuerbaren
energien beider länder zusammen hat
deutschland strom aus wind und sonne
übrig fließt er nach norwegen fehlt
hierzulande strom liefern die norweger
energie aus wasserkraft zu uns sie ist
winzig hatte riesenappetit und wird am
ende ein schmetterling die kleine raupe
nimmersatt frisst sich seit jahrzehnten
durch mittlerweile 50 millionen bücher
ihr schöpfer erika ist jetzt gestorben
mit 91 jahren
er wollte kindern mit seiner geschichte
mut machen sich entwickeln das heißt
sagte er sich verwandeln und seine
talente entfalten
im grunde so sagte karl sei er immer ein
kind geblieben
beim wetter noch mal regen mehr gleich
ganz ausführlich dann empfehle ich ihnen
das heute journal mit dem kollegen claus
kleber viertel vor zehn von uns allen
hier einen angenehmen abend und jetzt
viel spaß beim fußball
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die letzten
schauer lassen allmählich nach jetzt in
den nächsten stunden und dann lockert es
auf neun grad gibt es als t shirt im
osten und 4 grad an den alpen schauer
und gewitter am morgen noch einmal im
thema vor allem im osten
ansonsten lockert es weiter auf mit
sonnenschein im westen und süden und das
bei temperaturen bis 20 grad am
oberrhein und 13 grad im vogtland
die kommenden tage werden wärmer am
samstag noch im osten schauer bei 15 bis
20 grad sonntag bis 22 grad viel
sonnenschein und montag bis 23 grad und
damit ein schöner abend